hey everyone happy new year today it is
uh depending upon when you watch this
today is the first day of 2016 and I'm
spending it with two of my favorite
people two people one dog oh wait just
actually we celebrated also Jamie's
birthday today which happens to be on
the first so we had a nice little
birthday celebration for him and got to
see some of our friends and Maddy look
at you Pig
Jenna look with pants I'm wearing these
to hate the minions ah just a movie not
the pinyons yeah this is the movie the
minions movie conclusive yes the minions
actually are pretty awesome but I feel
like I haven't seen the movie but I
cannot comment Maddy look how cute you
are
sit high five I know what you do let's
go Zoe which one is mine hey can you can
you turn down bud thank you Matt for the
ice cream I've launched the way back
from Pittsburgh to LA and that flight is
so insane because the Pittsburgh Airport
isn't actually in Pittsburgh it's sort
of outside of Pittsburgh but it still
takes about an hour to get there from my
parents house so we had to get up at 3
o'clock and actually when I got up at
2:30 get to the airport by 4 ish do all
the airplane things we're not gonna go
up there no honey we're not gonna do
that but I won't make a video cuz a lot
of you guys were like hey did you film
anything on New Year's you've imposed a
video in a while and I thought about I
was like nope I actually edit in film on
New Year's I was so incredibly tired
that I just sort of was like I am on the
couch watching the Ryan Seacrest rerun
of the live show in New York I was so
upset we were all so upset because we
thought it was live but it was live on
the east coast here here's the problem
with the show is they're showing us the
East Coast ball drop in the same time
that it would be in the West Coast yeah
I just like oh I'm so excited Ellie
Goulding is gonna be on and like people
of East Coaster like weird I saw that
like three hours ago my problem is like
do they not know that else people on the
west coast know that it's not midnight
they're what they do I'm not sure I
would have thrown like
they show not sure but I really did
enjoy the Kathy Griffin Anderson Cooper
show I've never I've never watched the
CNN New Year's Eve
she's freaking nuts and I love it I want
to meet her this year that is my first
goal of 2016
Mattie look at you my main goal of 2015
was to make sure my dog survived his
first day of being brought home and
guess what he has survived he's now six
months old Mattie say hello quick quick
that that you're embarrassing mommy
don't do that
no no that's chocolate that's chocolate
thank you do you want any spoon I'll get
you new spillin not the spoons good
thank you oh okay you look good I just
want to look good
wait today was so amazing because we
just came up with this new show Matt
driving around and I sing rap lyrics in
the laxity what song do we sing what
song did I sing you say underground
Kingz about drave take care 2011 one
class and you also say some Freddie
Gibbs forever okay hmm Shawn Mendes
wasn't on the playlist Matt say one more
roughly scheme up Oh scheming up drank
now we know be obi-wan Kenobi that's on
wait should should I give them a little
taste of what yes what happened it's a
long way okay nothing that has anything
bad in it cuz I'm gonna have to bleep it
I'm sorry to Gomez on your place oh I
like that Selena Gomez song where the
how's it go good yeah is that rocket
uh-oh
awesome you like logic what oh yeah I
mean I don't know tell me what song I'm
gonna wrap it for you have you guys
heard of some Elton John wait a minute
qualified I did know some Jake you
should wrap Jacob Friday Night Lights
maybe a little bit uh okay today yep
okay what am I looking up Jake oh yeah
listen uh Jay Cool J Cole okay come here
buddy okay
I'm typing I type J cool lyrics what's
this on a God's gift God's gift what am
i doing I might how do I hear any
hip-hop fans out there no that's classic
up up and away would you trust me would
you love me and then must be well
watched owner omit I'm rain on the game
make it storm and thunder grab an
umbrella
not a stand under a bundle up is gonna
be a mama yo so let's uh game ticket
serious for Singapore if this gonna be a
rap show you gotta take it serious I am
really need to get go hard from bar to
bar mm-hmm now they come up out their
drawers how's that for a mistress he'll
bet heaven settin off yeah I think it's
good
well we doing a great job worldwide
stunner G oh man I'm a rain on the game
mega storm and thunder grab an umbrella
it's a cold ass summer yo so last summer
onto the new onto the Newton
wouldn't even save a CD when he seen me
two years later we made it onto the
blueprint I don't think I wrote it this
cold-ass the Mingo cuz we have a really
fantastic day hope you had a great New
Year's Eve hope you all were safe and
had a good time
and that's my doll we're having a good
time everyone you guys should go follow
DJ mini Matt's on Twitter and Instagram
oh wait wait you guys have to vote for
him for the dog awards because they're
gonna be cutting off the entries I think
very soon I'm gonna put a link in the
description you have got to go vote for
Maddie
under he's on himself to himself it's
under my new puppy and it's gonna be
amazing cuz he's gonna be like the dog
award
he is Maddie ready go the dog awards and
remember your choice
I know what Maddie did love the most in
this toy to toy body Maddie wait let's
show him let's do a group
[Music]
do you not like it
hey okay bye Happy New Year let's go
watch making of America already saw it
this is round two
[Music]
Oh